you're coming at this from a very
geometric standpoint I mean the circle
is what you might call a shape listen
man I'm gonna deduct 20 bucks for being
a smartass hey my name is Kevin and
today I'm challenging my co-workers to
see who can draw a perfect freehand
circle winner gets a hundred dollars
it's a perfect circle challenge shall we
welcome to the perfect starter challenge
thank you are you feeling I'm excited to
be here yeah practicing for the last 30
minute have you really I think small
circles you know I'm good it's the large
circles that things start to look like
an egg well Shelby I got some bad news
oh this is your center point okay this
is your radius I want you to draw
freehand circumference of a circle as
perfect as you can from that point all
the way back around or you can go that
way whichever way you want you can pick
up your hand I can't so you can do it in
segments if you want or that you just
have to be continuous line by the time
you're done okay that's a pretty big I
don't know that's why it's a challenge
you're not allowed to rotate the paper
[Music]
listen if you can rotate the paper then
everyone would win you don't think that
I accounted for that this is the perfect
circle challenge there is no oversight
on my end whoever gets closest to a
perfect circle freehand gets $100 $100
$100 stood alone so girls gotta hustle
any way she can dollar bill by itself
but in 20 so it's actually useful that's
right I had somebody buy something for
me on Craigslist attached only I've got
$100 bills in my apartment but I don't
even have a physical bank so I can't
like deposit even a physical thing you
got everything your mattress the last
rule is you only get one shot do not
miss your chance to blow opportunity
comes once in a lifetime mom's
sphaghetti hunters dollars cash money
are you ready for the perfect circle
challenge
[Music]
what's your strategy going in Cali just
ride it for a little bit okay okay
it's bracelets you got yes will you look
away yes I want to look this way it's
not look at me let me know when you're
done
confidence confidence let's do it is the
sound effect part of your gonna have to
start at some point obviously did this
thing what are we in elementary school
I'm not even sheet off your paper is
this how I take the SAT this is how I
you know write in my journal at night so
I can see where my points okay you're
thinking through this a lot and I like
it circles are a thinking man's game
yeah well it's not perfect but it's not
bad at all I like
tell me what happened she's getting up I
am staying up okay you know what I'm
gonna allow this Jasmine you're making a
mockery of the perfect circle challenge
purple circle challenge no which I was
looking at what are you gonna do you
can't really take the paper and try it
now
you may see this as not a curve more of
an angle that's well I missed it this is
my pencils you gave me the kind of like
sheet well we don't have pencil
[Music]
okay okay with that are you I'm gonna
have to okay this is the compass the
compass is the judge and compass doesn't
lie how do you think it it looks like B
- that's passing Oh Brendon Oh Brendon
oh goodness
this is the worst one it's not it's not
the best tell me about your technique
you would very quickly but you know I
just sleep on it I think you're using
that word correct I mean it's not
exactly correct right how do you think
you did
oh damn Josh great work I'm gonna say
you're one of the top contenders I've
gotta say like having your name here
that kind of throws you off it does
really throw it's the perfect circle
challenge why is this hard for people
it's three Bertus so having seen this
and having done it do you think it's
possible for someone to draw a perfect
freehand circle oh for sure no March of
there no it's not possible
why don't because we're Kingman I
believe in the human spirit and I think
we can do anything if we set our minds
to and there's someone out there you
could probably do a perfect circle with
their toes you can train to learn how to
do anything
it's just muscle memory are you gonna go
train no we got Josh very respectable
Tara did great
she's just a little bit shifted off but
I'm gonna say overall Josh still the
front-runner and I'm just Brendon Brenda
just came in and slayed it I think
Brendan's our winner
if you won the perfect circle challenge
$100 cash money but in living for you
perfect circle challenge that's it
congratulations to Brendan how would you
guys do the perfect circle challenge let
us know and maybe next time you can win
$100 cash money in the perfect circle
challenge
parisa don't challenge